Jonathan is with us Jonathan's in
California how are you Jonathan I'm
doing good Dave how are you better than
I deserve
how can I help all right so um I'm
calling in to ask a question I thought
about I think what you refer to as
gazelle intensity I've been there for
about six to eight months and I'm
hitting sort of like a rough patch over
the past year because about a year ago I
after having just proposed to my then
girlfriend a few days later I found out
that she had been unfaithful for a
number of months and I guess I don't
know from the past for the past year I
just haven't been able to stay motivated
and doing things like sticking to your
plan I've done things sort of like
trying to you know I picked up extra
jobs here and there how I'm 26
how long 26 26 okay cool all right and
how long had you dated this girl we were
together since we started in Community
College so five years until I found out
okay all right well I mean a normal
human being if you got messed over this
way after five years invested into a
relationship a girl you're deeply in
love with you and get engaged to and
then you found out she'd been messing
around on the side a normal human being
would that would be called a
heartbreaking situation a normal human
being would be down for a while if you
if that didn't knock you on your back
you'd be like a psychopath yeah I mean
you were in an emotional car wreck it
takes a little while to recover from a
big car wreck right yeah airbag deployed
smacked you in the face dude yeah yeah
so you got permission to hurt a little
I'll give you permission to hurt a
little I would have been crying and one
carrying on sucking my thumb blaming
everybody I mean I don't blame you
yeah my my main concern is that it's
it's a little bit weirder than that it's
you know it's been a year and since then
both she and I has attempted to
reconcile and yeah move on it's a deal
breaker yeah I mean you live you live a
lie of five years I'd move on you do
what you want to I'm just old man okay
but if you were my son I would tell you
cash your chips get off this table dude
not a chance I'd be walking and be
looking for somebody's gonna be the love
of your life let me tell you why you're
not winning financially and why your
career is not going to zoom zoom okay a
your hearts broken and your reason for
doing all of this was this beautiful
glorious future with rainbow and
skittles that you had mapped out they
got trampled on yeah okay
and that's you know what you have to
have in order to get excited again is to
have a reason to be excited and just
doing the stuff to do the stuff is not
exciting working your butt off to get
out of debt it's not exciting unless
there's something on the other end of it
what's your new why and the question you
have to ask yourself about this curl is
you're 26 let's pretend that everything
you get reconciled you go through
scowling and you get married and you're
35 and she comes home late from a girls
bridge party one night you're always
gonna wonder always